Hello Freak bitches. Anyway, thanks for
coming you guys. Thanks for having us.
It's a weird time.
You know,
I've been extra weirded out over the
last couple of months and I just got back
from Mexico. I was on vacation
and I didn't do shit for a week.
And in not doing anything for a week,
I really got a chance to sit
down and think about stuff.
And I'm more weirded out by life today
than I think I ever have been before.
So I'm excited to have you on because I
want to hear your story because Sam has
been telling me about it and I looked
into it and it's d please explain like
what happened to you, like where
you were and what happened to you.
Okay, so it was, uh, you're,
you're talking about the
panic attack was 2004.
I was on a little show that we do at ABC
news called Good Morning America shots,
a big show out, a little shell.
It's not a little show. And I was,
I was doing the job that I was
filling in as the newsreader.
That's the person who comes on at the
top of each hour and read the headlines.
And, uh, I just freaked
out. I just lost it.
So it was a couple of
seconds into it and I,
I started to get really scared and
it just, uh, if you've ever had,
have you ever had a panic of no.
So it's like anxiety on steroids,
so you start to worry, but then your
fight or flight instincts kick in. So, um,
your lung seize up, your palms
start sweating, your mouth dries up,
your heart is racing, your
mind is racing. You just,
I couldn't breathe and
therefore couldn't speak.
So a couple seconds into reading what
was supposed to be six stories right off
of the teleprompter,
I just,
I lost the capacity to speak and
I had to kind of squeak out. Uh,
something about, you know,
back to you, back to the main
anchors. Wow. That sucked.
Uncontrollable. No. What,
what caused it? Uh, no, I do.
Yeah, definitely. No. Um,
it's some dumb behavior in my
personal life is what caused it.
I had spent a lot of time as, as
a war reporter at ABC News. Um,
I was in Afghanistan and Pakistan,
Israel, the West Bank, Gaza, six,
six trips to Iraq. And, uh, I had
come home from a long run and I,
I covered, uh, Kinda the
pre-invasion invasion and then, uh,
insurgency in one's kind of six month run.
And I came home after that and I,
I got depressed and I didn't
actually know I was depressed,
but I was having some obvious
symptoms in hindsight. Uh,
I was having trouble getting out of bed.
I felt like I'd had a low
grade fever all the time.
And then I did something really smart,
which is I started to self medicate
with the cocaine and ecstasy. Uh,
and even though I wasn't
doing it all the time,
I like to say it wasn't
like that, you know, the,
you ever seen the wolf of Wall Street
where they're popping ludes that that
wasn't me. I W and I wasn't getting
high on the air or anything like that,
but you know,
I was getting,
I was partying in my spare time
because it made me feel better. Uh,
so after I had the panic attack,
I went to a doctor who's an in panic
and he started asking me a bunch of
questions, try to figure out what,
what, what had caused the panic attack.
And one of the questions was, do
you do drugs? And I was like, yeah,
I do drugs. And he leaned back in his
chair and gave me a look that's, uh,
communicated, uh, the following sentiment.
Um, okay, asshole, mystery solved.
And he just pointed out that,
you know,
you raised the level of adrenaline
in your brain artificially, uh, you,
you make it much more likely to have a
panic attack. And I at at, at baseline,
I'm a jittery little dude,
so it doesn't,
it doesn't take much
to put me in that zone.
We just offered me coffee and I said,
no, because even that will freak me out.
Well, it's weird that ecstasy and cocaine
was the combination because ecstasy is
something that they actually give
to a lot of soldiers that have PTSD.
And there's been quite a few
tests on that. Yeah. I don't,
I don't actually think ecstasy
was the problem. The coke,
I think it was a coke when it makes sense.
Yeah.
So those are the two drugs I was mostly
doing. How often were you doing it?
I would say,
you know,
there would be months where I wasn't doing
it at all because I would, I was off,
I covered the 2004 presidential campaign
and I didn't have a lot of time to be
snorting coke. So, um, but when
I was home and around my friends,
you know, on a good, on a busy week,
you know, two, three times a week. Wow.
That's a lot. Yeah, that'll
do. Yeah. There's a,
there's a comeback right now that,
uh,
cocaine is experiencing really ever go
away. Did, I dunno, I've never done it.
Was there some sort of cocaine recession
that it had to bounce back from?
Believe there was really, no, this is
what I'm talking totally. Ignorantly.
I'd been out of the game for a
long time, so, yeah. Yeah. I'm,
I'm kind of boring now. Um, uh,
but it feels to me like it's kind of a
perennial favorite. Yeah. I don't know.
I mean, I feel like it went through a
recession. Maybe it's just my perception.
I had a buddy of mine when I was in high
school and his cousin was a hooked on
coke and I watched while
we're in high school,
we start selling it and he withered away,
lost like 30 pounds or
something like that.
And just him and his girlfriend just
hide out in the attic. They lived,
they had an attic apartment.
They would just hide out there and watch
TV and do coke and sell coke to people.
And I was like, well, fuck
that drug, whatever that drugs
do. And like these people,
it's like, it was almost
like knowing someone who had
gotten bitten by a vampire.
Right. It becomes something
different. It was very strange.
So my experience is seeing people
do that led me to never do it. Yeah.
I mean, it certainly was not like
that for me, but you know, I,
I could see it over the horizon. You can,
it's an incredibly addictive drug. Um,
so I think you've made the right
call. Yeah. It seems a little,
it's got a little too much gravity
attached to it. Yeah. I mean, you, you,
you can get hooked and it will bring you
down. There are other drugs you can do.
I'm not recommending drugs, but, uh, the
way my friends, Sam, my half brother,
Sam over there,
uh,
there are other drugs, drugs you can do
that have vastly lower addictive, uh,
a character, a character. What's the word
I'm looking for here? So, characteristics.
Yes. Thank you. Um, so
how did you recover?
I,
so I wasn't actually doing it that long.
I actually never done hard
drugs into my early thirties,
and when I came home from the war zones
and, um, and that's what started it. Yeah.
Yeah. Just were freaked out by seeing too
much. No, it's actually, it wasn't PTSD.
Uh, it was, I was addicted to the
adrenaline I was having. I was,
it was not that I was traumatized,
it was that I was enjoying it too much
and I would come home in the world would
seem gray and boring. Uh, yes. That was,
that was the problem. Did you watch hurt
locker? I'm sure he did it right. Yeah.
Did that resonate with you? It's been
awhile since I watched it, but apps,
absolutely.
I want to just be clear
that the experience of a
journalist is so different from
the experience, so much more
mild than the experience of, uh,
an enlisted man or a woman.
So I don't want to compare my
experience to the hurt locker. I'm a,
I'm a observer on the side and I,
and,
and I don't even want to compare my
experience to more experienced war
correspondents out there. I'm thinking
of like guys like Richard Angle on NBC.
Absolutely. I just actually sat
down with him the other day for,
he's got a new documentary coming out.
Um,
my experiences are much
more mild than that,
but certainly enough to really get
a sense of how thrilling it is.
There's an expression,
there's nothing more thrilling than the
bullet that misses you. And in my case,
luckily they all missed. That was
not true for some of my friends. Um,
but you, so I had a real sense of
the stakes. But 80 is exciting. Uh,
it's also thrilling on a, um,
on a idealistic level. I mean,
I believe in the importance of
bearing witness to the what?
To the tip of the spear,
to what we're doing,
to what our military is doing in our name.
So all of that is a heady mix.
So you knew people over
there, a journalist that got
killed? Oh yeah, absolutely.
A very good friend of mine,
the guy who actually ultimately set
me up with my wife is a guy named Bob
Woodruff, who was the anchor of
world news tonight on ABC News.
He had only been in the chair for about
a month when he was on a trip to Iraq
and he got hit,
literally got his head,
and you're really blown off
when he was in the back,
when he was in the top of an Iraqi tank.
Uh,
almost died is an
absolute miracle is alive.
There are pictures of him on the
Internet with basically half ahead. Um,
traumatic brain injury was
brought back to life. Is,
is to this day walking
miracle that he's alive. Uh,
and after he recovered, he then
introduced me to the woman I married.
Uh, so he's a close friend and I, uh,
I saw cases like that and lost friends,
both Iraqi friends and
journalists, friends. Um, my,
the woman I was dating at the time when I,
when I was spending a lot of time in
Iraq, she got hit by a tank shell. Um,
she was in, in the, the hotel
Palestine where all the were staying.
She was on a balcony in, or one of
her colleagues in the balcony below,
or he got a direct hit and died. Uh, he,
she carried him to the hospital and she
basically got the reverberations and
couldn't hear. Still can't
hear as far as I know. Hmm.
Ooh.
When you're a journalist and you're
over in Iraq or in Afghanistan,
you're in war,
and what you're experiencing is so far
removed from the day to day life that
most people experience. What, what is
it like trying to relay that to people?
How difficult is it trying to cause so
I think so many people have this almost,
um,
dramatic television movie slash view of,
of war where they don't,
they don't ever experience it.
Like I would imagine probably 99% of
the people that are in this country will
never expect it.
No. And that's good. Um, no, it's,
it's, it's, I don't know that you can,
uh, uh, describe it, uh,
in a way that will really give
the full picture of it's, uh,
absurdities and horrors and long
stretches of boredom punctuated by terror.
Um,
and also this other piece,
which is taboo to talk about,
which is the pleasure and excitement.
Then people get fighting wars. I mean,
they go, this is Sebastian
younger thesis as well. I mean,
there's just a camaraderie is the most
intense comradery they ever experienced.
And so that, that's something they come
back to civilian life and are missing it.
And, and it's part of what's
so difficult about coming back
and that's why you see them a lot of,
uh, risk taking behavior among, uh,
vets, um, eat,
because I know that you're looking for
another way to get that hit of adrenaline
for sure. There was a, uh, there's
a book and I'm blanking on the name,
is a great book written by a much more
experienced war corresponded to me.
He used the phrase war is a
drug and that to me sums it up,
at least in my experience,
I got hooked on the experience of being
in these really elevated situations,
heightened situations,
cinematic dramatic situations.
And I would come home and I just,
I didn't know what to do to replace it.
And so this synthetic squirt of adrenaline
that you can get from cocaine seem to
do it for me, obviously had
tremendously negative consequences.
And so I wouldn't recommend it,
but I see why people do this.
So how did you,
how did you bounce back?
Oh,
that was actually the question you asked
me before that I somehow neglected to
answer.
So the doctor who pointed out that I was
okay,
an idiot and doing drugs and
it caused the panic attack, uh,
I agreed he didn't think I needed
to go to rehab because it was the,
it was pretty short lived. It was, I
was in my early thirties when I started,
and it's still in my early
thirties when I had a panic attack.
And so it was only a
couple of, he said, just,
I want you to come see me once or
twice a week, forever, a forever.
He said basically indefinitely. Um, so
I still see him, but not, not, yeah,
it's a good business model, but not that,
I mean, it's been, well north of, uh,
it's been about 13 years,
so I don't see him that often now,
but for a long time I saw him
intensively. Uh, so that, uh, you know,
it wasn't easy. It's not easy.
Um, and I wouldn't have, I
wouldn't call what, I mean,
there are people who have
had drug addictions that
are vastly more severe than
mine. Right. Um, but it's, uh,
it sucks to stop a habit that is
giving you pleasure on, you know,
pretty in pretty, um,
prominent areas of your brain.
Yeah.